I'm Doug Hamilton I'm waste management
specialist for the Oklahoma Cooperative
Extension Service and you you may wonder
why a guy from Oklahoma is talking about
alligators
I'll show you we do have alligators in
the wild in the southeast corner of the
state in the marshes along the Red River
but we have no alligator production in
Oklahoma oops
but the interesting thing is a lot of
the cultures that developed in alligator
country the Seminole of the Muscogee the
trucked all picado now are residents of
the state of Oklahoma
so if Osceola the Seminole national hero
would to see an alligator he would have
called that hook Lata that's how you
pronounce that but why I am while you're
listening to me today is we have a waste
management channel on YouTube where we
were looking and we are looking at
different types of waste systems so that
farmers can see virtually before they
get into a particular practice and back
in 2010 we went down to Louisiana dr.
Ron Sheffield was doing some treatment
for alligator wastewater and with his
passing and I guess I've become the de
facto national expert on alligator waste
why do we have farms with alligators
there's a number of products that come
from alligators the number one
moneymaker for them is leather they grow
the alligators up to about four feet in
length four for leather
the growth of an alligator is really
regulated by temperature so if you have
a ninety ninety two degree temperature
they'll get to four foot in about a year
or 12 months they like to raise them
slower so they'll drop the temperature
down to 80 82 degrees and they end up
with a much more beautiful leather and
that takes about 16 to 18 months to get
up to four feet the second big products
are the valley Gators is the meat
and when you look at an alligator it's
almost all tail so the tail meat has
used the restaurants county fairs you
can get fried alligator tail I haven't
seen it in the store probably if I'm in
Florida or Louisiana they have it in the
store their number three item is novelty
items you can get keychains with an
alligator foot
they sell the teeth here we have a head
I can imagine back when I was in college
I could see this in someone's dorm room
with an ashtray in the middle of it and
then the fourth thing is tourism
there's farms that let you come watch
them feed the alligators instigator
ranch the the place we were filming view
they have a little kiddie pool and you
can play with the alligators they have
hurt their mouths are taped shut
also they let you hold an alligator egg
in your hands while it's hatching the
Nate the alligators themselves are kind
of an interesting Beast I don't think we
have any other confined animals feeding
operations that are actually reptiles
there may be some snake farms I don't
know but the alligator is interesting
that their Anatomy is more or their
digestive anatomy is more in line with
birds than anything else they have to
parts of their stomach they have a
gizzard somewhat like a chicken they
also like chickens and birds they only
they they do not have a urethra so all
of their urine mixes with feces and
exits through what they call the cloak
wall which would be the anus in a in a
in a mammal and like birds about 70% of
all the nitrogen excreted by an
alligator is in the form of uric acid
the other thing that's kind of different
about alligators than most of our
domestic species is they're an apex
predator so they are fed a very high
protein diet in the wild they eat eat
their food whole but we generally have
some kind of a manufactured feed and
that feed is going to be about 50%
protein comparatively cat food which is
also fairly high protein is about 20% so
if you want to look to analogous animal
to an alligator you'd have to look at
your apex aqueous apex predators in the
burgh kingdom bald eagles osprey that
sort of thing
now there's two basic ways that the
alligators are raised on farm the first
one is the alligator farm and that's
predominant in Florida some in Georgia
southern Alabama what makes a alligator
farm an alligator farm is all the
breeding stock are raised on that farm
they have the mother alligators and I'm
assuming the father alligators and they
lay the eggs and they harvest all of the
4-foot or marketable Gators so you could
call that a closed system in the state
of Louisiana it's kind of unique the
Louisiana Department of Wildlife and
Fisheries issues licenses to alligator
ranchers and they go out and collect
eggs from the wild and then they
released into 15% of the four-foot
alligators out in the wild the 10 to 15%
comes from the fact that in nature only
about 15% at most of the hatchlings are
going to live up to the be 4 foot about
1 year and so you could call that an
open system and that that the animals
are taken from the wild and are returned
to the wild most almost this is the
slight Regina seen our from the
instigator ranch almost all of the
alligators raised in the United States
are raised under roof there still may be
a few open systems in Florida but none
of them in Louisiana this particular
farm they have three barns and then they
have one long pit in each in each barn
at which are separated up into pens very
similar to a slatted floor hog barn for
instance the alligators spend most the
time in the water you see there's a
little ledge here in the corner where
they can crawl up on and they also feed
them on that ledge
just like a hog barn that pit is filled
through the pit recharge system they
have a well that fills the pit and then
they can pull that the pull plug in the
middle and it's going to let all the
water out the entire length of the barn
they get in there with a pressure washer
and wash out all the solids the
alligators love that in fact they are
constantly spraying the alligators at
least in the summertime for for heat
control
you might ask what an alligator is fed
all of the alligator ranches in
Louisiana have some form of prepared
feed this guy was actually buying his
food from Land O'Lakes Purina they
actually stored a gator child to him one
of the things that the people at least
in Louisiana are very sensitive to you
may have heard of people that started
raising alligators for mortality method
for poultry farms those types of people
are fairly ostracized by the alligator
ranching community they like to they
take pride in their product and and the
raising them them for them is a fairly
serious business although they do the
tourism this is what the influent coming
out of those barges looks like the pipe
on the left is a pit that had the the
plugs pulled so that's going to be the
the manure and throw from the pit and
the one on the right that's just the
overflow from all those sprinklers in a
particular bar this farm used a holding
pond to hold waste and then they
irrigated it onto about a 20 or 25 or 30
acre field and they were using the
Kaline pods they would pull them out
with a four-wheeler move them around the
one thing you might ask particularly
once how did they size that field well
it just happened they had that much land
and if you women and trying to do a
nutrient management plan on an alligator
farm you'd quickly find that there is no
book data on alligator manure and
characteristics in our si si si ve is
not going to have that date
anywhere and it's pretty hard to find
even on online or excuse me in referee
journal articles we I am working on a
fact sheet that's a companion to this
talk we so what I'm saying is the the
best way to size a facility is to take
samples of the the influent or the
effluent and then get good volume
estimates and try to base it it's
probably going to fall on phosphorus
loss heights but we will have some
information out fairly soon giving you
NPK concentrations for that came out of
a thesis that Ron Sheffield was working
on Sheffield was there mostly because
the guy was interested in treating
further treating that holding pond waste
and his number-one concern was odor
control he was in Covington Louisiana
which is a suburb of New Orleans right
across Lake Pontchartrain and he had
some pretty high priced houses in his
neighborhood so he's interested in
controlling an older that's basically
reducing your organic matter and also
transferring and solid nutrients to the
solid phase so if you wanted to go
transported further he could do that
some treatment system with potential for
alligator waste where the first comes to
mind would be Lagoon one of the
drawbacks Lagoon is that with that
higher protein feed it may not help you
much with the odor control you can see
on the one of his barns he's got a
windsock that's not for a helicopter
landing he actually monitored the wind
direction so that he knew when was a
good data to spread and when was not a
good day to spread what dr. Sheffield
was working on was a calcium phosphate
precipitation system where they would
precipitate the phosphates out and take
most of their organics with them you can
see here the the liquid on the right is
after it's gone through the process had
very little odor it looked clear but it
probably had a fairly
ammonia concentration also I'd be amiss
since we're work with anaerobic
digestion here in Oklahoma and we also
work with a liquid digestion system so
anaerobic digestion to knock down the
organics followed by struvite
precipitation wouldn't achieve pretty
much the same goals that's my last slide
I want to thank John Price who is the
owner manager of the instigator ranch
for allowing us to go down there and of
course Ronald Sheffield
the late great Ronald Sheffield was the
inspiration behind everything in Craig
woods was our videographer and most of
the the slides you see here were screen
safe from from our video I will be
coming out with that fact sheet shortly
you can contact me there or that's my
personal website at least for the next
couple of months until extension changes
things